what is going on with stream labs and
obs up next here on code news i wanted
to do this before too many non-coder
news youtubers start saying stuff they
don't understand but we're gonna cover
the basics first alright so what
happened here what's all this drama with
obs well i will quickly go over it and
please if i miss anything or i'm
overlooking something let me know down
below let us know down below and we'll
try to figure all right editor matt
popping in here
trying to get this out to you guys um i
realize i missed a few things there was
a lot of other accusations of things
that got copied and ripped off from
other companies that i don't address in
this video but i'm going to leave a link
down below to a video made by a guy
named
i don't know what his name is alpha
gaming who covers a lot of the other
ripoffs we're not going to be covering
those we're mainly going to be looking
at strictly obs and stream labs so
so really this all started with a tweet
from obs
and here's what it is it's uh
well i'm not sure if this is exactly how
it started near the launch of slobs
streamlabs obs streamlabs reached out to
us about using the obs name we kindly
asked them not to they did so anyway and
followed up by okay i guess this is the
tweet that started it in case you
haven't figured out the very base of
this so obs is used for streaming and
recording i use it all the time obs or
obs studio and stream labs of course
made their own version and that we're
going to go over and we're going to look
at some of this code too and analyze a
little more about how this is all done
so look forward to that okay so obs
project this is the first one the main
one legally they have obeyed the terms
of the gpl but have repeatedly
disregarded the spirit of open source
alright so this is a bit tricky uh okay
despite the actions obs project will
continue to provide free open source so
obs and
is not too happy about this obviously
now there's one thing missing here that
i haven't been able to find and i wonder
if anybody's been able to find it
there's this call out here all right the
big call out
but i have not seen the receipts for
this doesn't mean they're not there
doesn't mean they're wrong
i it seems like they're being honest
especially given that stream labs
followed up and
kind of acknowledged it but there's no
indication of these messages there's no
uh i want to see these reach out what
did what was said what did streamlabs
say what did obs say back no one's seen
that all we've got is these tweets as
far as i know so is that enough to
believe all this well according to the
internet yes now it's also important to
note here that
as we looked at
no laws were violated so no legal action
is actually able to be taken here other
than maybe with the name obs
because the whole issue is streamlabs
took this obs and just put it onto their
product and if we just hop over to
reddit we can try to find a little bit
more information and do some digging on
these posts sometimes people have
links and stuff to things that are
relevant so i'm going to have a gander
and see what we can find and
here well this is just kind of more of
the sentiment of what's going on this
guy thought the streamlabs partnered
with obs to put software out for the
longest time they're not partnered they
just took the name that is the whole
problem there is this whole illusion
that they're in cahoots together that
there are projects that work to the
other teams work together and they don't
at all obs is open source
so that you can uh use it in its code
and also streamlabs obs is also open
source so you can use their stuff as
well that's not really exactly relevant
to this but just throwing that out there
and naturally we got some big names
throwing their hat in the ring really
thought they were associated with you
guys just different version thank you
for the software it's revolutionized the
way many of us do our jobs that's from
jacksepticeye
who thought they were associated and
ammunition thought they were a
collaborative product as well i thought
streamlabs made obs okay so the big
thing here is just everybody thinks
they're the same product because the
name and
yeah that's a bit
shady there's definitely something
shady about that
and naturally the the world of the
internet is kind of going on a rampage
about this whole thing and really
showing the original obs project a lot
of sport and really bashing stream labs
and i've even heard people live
streaming say they're switching off
stream labs obs and going back to obs
studio but they got to change their
setup and adapt things or maybe they're
going to stream elements and it's just
really
kind of crazy
in a way i'll give you my opinion
shortly i'm kind of just reviewing what
other people are saying right now all
right and there's just a lot of
streamers just coming out and just
showing support for obs it just it's
it's cool to see
and a lot of people just saying hey
reminder that streamlabs obs is not obs
don't think you're supporting obs when
you're supporting streamlabs that seems
to be the core issue is just that
confusion with people going and
supporting streamlabs
obs thinking they're supporting the
people that actually made obs which
isn't the case
now i did see somewhere that streamlabs
said that they were going to be renaming
and taking the obs off of their name but
i cannot find it for the life of me i
think it was somewhere in a tweet but
i've looked over their twitter and i
can't find it but
streamlabs somewhere did say that
they're going to take the obs off the
name and
the general response to that was yeah
since you got caught now you're going to
change your name but you didn't just
have respect to begin with so people
aren't super thrilled but
at least they're taking action and
trying to do the right thing
streamlabs obviously shouldn't have used
the name obs in their name if the
original creator said hey i prefer that
you don't but it doesn't change the fact
that uh there are no receipts for that
conversation as far as we know
and i'm just playing devil's advocate
here the original obs guy could have
just made that up a couple days ago just
because they were annoyed with
streamlabs they're like alright let's
put this out there but you know anybody
can say anything like that way later but
if you don't have the original messages
where you politely ask them not to use
the name to begin with who knows if
they're lying or not now i don't think
they're lying just plain devil's
advocate to be very clear on that i
would love to see
the original messages i'm sure we all
would it seems like in general and this
is one thing that kind of bothers me is
nobody seems to care about that they're
just kind of blindly believing the
accusation which uh i don't think you're
supposed to be doing i don't i'm not a
lawyer but pretty sure that's not
something you do if you accuse someone
of something especially something that's
gonna really like mess up your
reputation you kind of need some proof
that uh what you're saying is true and
of course there's obviously proof of the
name they're obviously using the name
obs but they did very clearly state in
their tweet that uh they asked him to
not use the name and it was ignored i
just want to see that original message
if it exists do you or does it matter
let me know so is it worth back
switching back to just obs studio no
there is a reason that people use
streamlabs obs and it's because it adds
a lot of nice functionality for
streamers that can't be discounted
there's a lot of people that aren't
going to switch because they're going to
lose a lot of their features or it's
going to be annoying for them to have to
reset up all their stream stuff and they
might lose days of content doing so it
seems clear
that it's not like streamlabs is
only stealing they are adding something
that is useful to people despite
stealing the name
it's not like they're just completely
saying this is tricky to say right maybe
i'm just going to stop there you guys
probably get the point all right and now
we're going to get to the point where
we're going to look at some of this code
all right we're going to look at obs
these are all open source projects so
the original obs i think this is the
original i'm not exactly a
code historian on this but the original
one by jp 9000 looks like it was put
together last releases in 2016. so this
is kind of a dated project but obs
studio i don't know exactly what
happened here i don't know
uh how it went from obs to obs studio or
what's going on there but obs studio is
hugely popular and seems to be where all
the current updates to obs are actually
going obs studio just offers some
additional features and it's just still
part of the obs project so yeah i guess
they do say here that this is
depreciated see obs studio instead so it
looks like it got changed over to obs
studio but it's cool having a look at
the original code and here's obs studio
all the code we don't want to dig in
like super deep because it's going to
get confusing but you can support them
highly recommended if you use the
software i plan on doing so as soon as i
can i'm recording on obs studio right
now i also do use stream labs for
streaming sometimes but i could go
either way literally the only reason i
use both of them is just so i can have
two separate profiles a profile for
recording in a profile or streaming and
it's just easy to have two separate
programs but i'm not particularly
attached to streamlabs so i could ditch
it if i really wanted to and
as you might be able to tell so far yeah
i kind of want to just to support obs
but also it's gonna mess up my flow and
take a bunch of time so
i'm gonna see what comes of this in the
long run before i make that final
decision
all right the code
so you can see from the obs project
they've got c and c plus plus c make
objective c mainly c and c plus plus
so this is primarily built with c plus
plus which is awesome cool and you can
go look at the exact code you can see
exactly how they do everything they've
got direct 3d opengl lots of lots of
stuff
all public for coders like you and me to
go learn from
all right cool so as long as you follow
the license you can use this stuff
you could make your own whatever using
this all right so let's look at
streamlabs now and this is where things
get interesting streamlabs
all right so this is free and open
source streaming software built on obs
and electron now i got to give them some
credit for making this open source they
they might have to based on the license
i don't know i'm not a licensed expert
so i guess you guys can hash that out if
you know better
but basically they use electron which is
just a way to
code up a interface basically with html
and javascript and all that i'm not an
expert with that but electron i think is
used to make slack and some other
programs it's just good for uh making
windowed software basically
so they basically
say they use obs and electron to make
this whole new interface and version so
let's take a look here
if we look at the languages used in all
this code there's not a single bit of c
and not a single bit of c plus now why
is that because they're not writing a
single bit they're using exactly obs
source code and bringing that in it's
like a sub module yeah they're using
typescript to do their interface and
some view for probably their layouts
and they're basically just coding up an
interface around obs and then calling it
streamlabs obs that's where the issue
really came in we really don't like that
they use that obs name i don't know
where it is exactly but there's
something in here that basically brings
in the obs project so that they can work
on top of it now it's pretty cool that
they have all their electron code and
all that and they tell you how to build
it if you want to build it and looks
like they've probably added some new
stuff here
let's see when was this readme updated
let's look at the readme where he had
updated 12 hours ago
so after being called out and shamed
they have decided to finally acknowledge
how important obs is basically at its
core streamlabs desktop is powered by
obs desktop so this this is new they
didn't have this here before they
weren't really given a big shout out to
obs it wasn't clear
that they were not the developers of obs
but now it is being made clear and i
think this is a this is definitely a
good thing but really yes of course they
should have been doing this to begin
with i don't know what they were
thinking by not giving them proper
credit to begin with honestly that is a
little weird
but they still were doing what they
legally were supposed to do and
following the
gpl license as far as i understand
i want to know what you guys think it's
really nice to see people supporting the
original product and clarity being made
about
the difference between stream labs obs
and obs and yes they definitely need to
be changing their name
off of the stream labs obs that makes
sense i think given all the confusion
and the community feedback and it sounds
like they've agreed to so they're
trying to do the right thing but
is it true that they're only doing it
because they're getting called out and
basically hated by the public for it
according to those original tweets where
the obs project said that they
didn't obey what they asked to begin
with it seems like streamlabs is in the
wrong would love to see the original
conversation just proof that it happened
proof that they asked them not to use
the name and they did it anyway because
anybody could just blindly accuse anyone
of anything and they'd flow through but
given that streamlabs said okay we'll
change rene our name that kind of admits
it's like a guilty admission because i
didn't see anything
of streamlabs saying like hey uh you
never actually asked so they're kind of
acknowledging that to begin with but is
that enough proof well that's that's the
drama just covering a little code drama
this doesn't really affect most of us
too much but there's a few important
lessons to learn here and i think the
biggest thing is to just give credit to
the people who enabled your project
especially if they're the core of it
just pretending to be the person who
made the core of it is really shady in
general if you're making a project that
inherits from something else
yeah it's just not good for any open
source developer to have their work
stolen it it gives a
it gives a lot of incentive for
future developers to hide their code
because they don't want it stolen so
yeah we gotta we gotta shame streamlabs
at least a little for doing that sort of
shady tactic thanks for watching if you
like seeing these sort of code drama
news videos please let me know by
leaving a like and subscribing to the
channel it would mean a lot and also
join become a member of code tech and
tutorials for some bonus stuff in bonus
content and it really really helps me
continue to make videos
and supports me going forward in this
whole youtube endeavor that i'm doing so
thank you very much guys i'll see you in
the next one peace out
[Music]
[Music]
you